Jimmy thing here with Scott Butterworth
and Scott you had the chance to check
out some PlayStation VR titles recently
you yeah yeah just I thought I was at
the the sony press conference said did
this whole big PR event directly
afterwards and showing a bunch of stuff
that they announced during press
conference actually so a lot of games
we've already seen like 100 foot robot
golf and harmonica are but also tons of
stuff that was to us and out last night
cool can you walk us through some of the
biggest pedals a phone so let's see saw
some final fantasy as the Final Fantasy
15 VR experience I just the first person
looks like yeah it's a shooter here it
doesn't really feel like much of a
fantasy game I mean it's just a straight
up like first person shooter experience
basically you're fighting one giant boss
with the help of some of the other
characters from the upcoming game but
you can kind of like warp around the
environment but no really it's just like
you have the one move controller and
you're aiming at the boss and like just
shooting until it dies and that's kind
of the entire experience that you know
if it's gonna be multiplayer is that why
the other character is about that I've
the demo and they really weren't willing
to divulge any other information asked
if that's going to be you know more
levels or a different gameplay and all
of its to be determined even the release
dates to be determined so it was
interesting to see those characters cut
up close and personal and to see all
that in VR but yeah it didn't really
feel like any final fantasy game that
I've ever played it was it was a bit of
a weird little demo so I don't know if
it election results in a full game but
that's the last night experience was so
wasn't super crazy about this experience
but then again like finding pants and ER
it's kind of a sugar pea with yeah yeah
just shooter gameplay is it like a laser
gun is it kind of like machine gun like
what kinda just a pistol your only
option least last night was just this
pistol actually another shooter I saw
that did have a machine gun though
Farpoint which actually led with during
the press conference seven sort of their
first big our title that they showed
that one was actually a little bit
disappointing too it's just kind of a
very very straightforward sci-fi shooter
it's just you on a kind of Mars looking
rocky dusty planet shooting a bunch of
bug alien type of things again the
environments were pretty believable it
was really cool to get to walk around
and it does have this crazy peripheral
that was just announced it's basically
the successor to the the doors like what
was it the sure shot the move sheer shot
back when the PlayStation Move was a
thing during the PS three days sure
it's kind of a version of that if like
this rifle peripheral and it actually
has a joystick and a d-pad on it so you
use that to maneuver through the
environment but you still aim and shoot
using the the trigger and the headset I
know talking the other day you said
Batman was surprisingly that was
surprisingly cool so for anybody could
split the Arkham games if you know like
the detective sections where you're
analyzing a crime scene it was basically
that but in VR so you get actually
barrows Prime yeah exactly the all the
first person so you can view the crime
from multiple angles kind of same things
final fantasy where there were certain
spots around the environment you can
warp to but because it wasn't action it
didn't actually feel as limiting you
could basically just like scrub through
the playback by twisting your wrist with
the move controller in your hand so the
whole the whole experience is framed is
basically a murder mystery we're trying
to solve the murder of Dick Grayson
which is kind of a cool narrative
concede according to deficits only about
an hour long experience but what I
played so far was actually like pretty
cool what else did you check out let's
see oh another thing was resident evil
that would I hate so for anybody that
saw the conference that room that you
see in that trailer that you're kind of
like walking through this derelict house
like peeling wallpaper and all that kind
of stuff that's basically what the demo
was I think this is actually the same
level that's playable on the
downloadable demo on PSN what I at the
Clayton VR so it's really cool you play
with a dual strap for so it's about what
you would expect from the controls and
move it and all that but you actually
can look around the environment and you
feel a little bit more immersed actually
being in first person in the world it's
kind of hard to feel too scared when
you're standing around a bunch of other
people in a giant room so I don't know
if the emerging is really gonna make the
experience any scarier it's kind of hard
to say but it's definitely cool getting
to like explore this cold environment in
first-person NVR you know I can't even
play like horror games like on a
straight flat monitor so let alone like
in BR yeah that's like a no for me
thanks I think the last game that I
probably wanna talk about sort of number
52 round at the list psychonauts vr for
anybody doesn't know psychonauts uh you
know the original gang came out I think
like a little over 10 years ago and they
finally announced they're doing a full
sequel but they're also doing a separate
standalone VR game that kind of links
the two called rhombus of ruin so they
were showing that last night as well and
it's really cool it's like all the
original voice actors all the writing
still done by tim schafer so it feels
very much like a psychonauts game but
the way they kind of get around the game
plays since the original game was more
platformer you're basically it's a
seated experience first person first
person and you can transfer your
consciousness to different characters
around the room what functions is a bit
of a traversal mechanic because
everyone's kind of situated in different
parts of the environment if you jump
into their mind you can suddenly view
the room from make sense within the
context of the game's narrative yeah
totally because it's all about you know
psychics basically the name is about
people with psychic abilities so yeah
you have like a clairvoyant abilities
which you can also light things on fire
with your mind or move things with your
mind so it's kind of like a puzzle game
meets the humor and writing of the
original psychonauts so so to escape the
room kind of thing you got to figure out
puzzles to progress in yeah yeah well
yeah I mean you move the experience
along by solving puzzles I don't know
that I related to escape anything before
the scenes that I played was actually
took place immediately after the end of
the first game and the puzzles were fun
it was really cool it gets kind of move
stuff with my mind and I could pick some
up with the controller but I would
actually move as I looked around was
using the PlayStation Move controllers
are those yes what okay and like I said
there was a ton of other stuff but for
me those were the five kind of biggest
game so that people we want to hear
about awesome for more III coverage stay
tuned to gamespot com
you